más de 16.000 nuevos casos de
coronavirus han sido diagnosticados en
francia un triste nuevo récord diario el
número de pacientes gravemente enfermos
con el virus también está creciendo con
más de 1000 actualmente en cuidados
intensivos el número más alto desde el 8
de junio todo esto ha hecho temer que
francia se dirija hacia un segundo
confinamiento aquí en foco lo tiñó el
público debe estar atento y ser prudente
más que efectiva siguen así son para si
no actuamos podríamos encontrarnos en
una situación similar a la de la
primavera dance en situación por ciento
cercana conmigo cuando significaría un
nuevo confinamiento podría ser pero lo
queremos evitar las restricciones en
ciertas partes de francia ya han sido
reforzadas la ciudad sureña de marsella
ha sido declarada en alerta máxima lo
que significa que a partir del sábado
todos los bares y restaurantes tendrán
que cerrar totalmente por lo menos
durante 15 días
parís está en alerta elevada las
reuniones públicas se han limitado a
díaz individuos y los grandes eventos
públicos como el deporte tienen
límite de 1000 personas pero la noticia
de las nuevas medidas draconianas
impuestas a marsella ha dejado a los
propietarios de negocios aterrorizados
de que las reglas puedan ser aún más
estrictas
[Música]
tenemos mucho miedo de que nos pase lo
de marcilla y guadalupe sabemos que
estamos en la capital de dos modos que
ya es una zona roja y dejamos de un
abuso en sólo tres semanas el número de
pacientes de kobe 19 en los hospitales
de parís se ha más que duplicado
sobrepasando los 300 y las autoridades
dicen que podrían duplicarse de nuevo a
finales de mes